[Musique]
sa valise qui nous protège monde
extérieur parce qu'on est trop jeune
pour ça mais au final on protège pas
juste qu'on me colle et dumont hector
est ce que je n'avais pas la liberté
d'expression c'est comme d'une sucrerie
il faut l'utiliser avec modération la
parole est libre dans l'hémicycle du
département pour l'assemblée du conseil
départemental des jeunes organisés en
groupes depuis plusieurs jours il
rassemble ce matin leurs pensées sur le
thème la liberté d'expression oui mais
comment et jusqu'où une question
débattue par ses deux rapporteurs de
groupe libérez net paroles de bad est
libre de plus libres de nos choix de de
ce qu'on dit de ce qu'on fait de se
sentir mois inférieur au niveau des bas
des adultes et d'être plus apte à nous
accepter nous et d'accepter que nous
aussi on peut parler nous aussi on a une
réflexion et nous si on est important
dans cette société
ça nous permet de nous exprimer et de
pouvoir mettre des choses en place
malgré qu'on soit mineur qu'on soit plus
jeune que d'autres personnes et qu'on
est quand même des choses à dire existe
déjà c'est pas qu'on voudrait exister
c'est qu'on soit plus plus considérer
que que d'habitude motiver ces jeunes
portent la parole d'une génération
raison pour laquelle il fallait lancer
le débat l'association l'école du
bonheur agit localement et représente le
cofrade le conseil français des
associations pour les droits de l'enfant
moi je pense qu'on ne leur donne pas
suffisamment ou alors pas comme il le
faudrait
savage souvent en fait ils parlent ils
parlent mais est ce qu'on les écoute il
faut savoir que le monde d'aujourd'hui
ce qui est valable aujourd'hui n'est
peut-être pas valable pour demain et les
solutions qu'on a aujourd'hui ne sont
pas celles qui sont roux peut-être
valable demain donc c'est important en
fait de questionner les jeunes parce
qu'on leur donne pas suffisamment la
parole les échanges avec les experts
médias juriste et philosophe permettent
de donner de la consistance au débat et
si tous ces jeunes s'accordent à dire
que communiquer entre eux serait une
solution
le plus important est de s'autoriser à
on ne cède pas rôle les jeunes il faut
savoir saisir les opportunités et
vraiment s'exprimer faire partie opinion
parce que souvent on est timide réservée
on reste dans son coin mais on a
toujours des choses à dire et je pense
qu'il faut donner son avis justement
aller de l'avant et s'exprimer vraiment
c'est une clé en fait le 11 décembre
prochain un groupe de cinq jeunes
représentera la réunion à l'assemblée
nationale lors des états généraux des
droits de l'enfant
[Musique]